à l'heure où nous écrivons ce reportage
120 femmes sont mortes sous les coups de
leur conjoint ou ex conjoint depuis le
1er janvier 2019
parmi ces féminicide quatre se sont
déroulées dans les yvelines
le collectif citoyen nous tout organise
des réunions locales pour sensibiliser
la population
cette réunion c'est à la fois une
réunion de sensibilisation sur les
mécanismes des violences pour que les
gens et les chiffres en tête qui
comprennent un peu mieux commencer et
violent se met en place et c'est aussi
une réunion de mobilisation pour la
grande marche nationale qui aura lieu le
23 novembre
je te crois exemples de phrases a
prononcé à une victime qui viendrait se
confier dans le département elles sont
une quinzaine à prendre le temps de
délivrer ses conseils
une démarche saluée par les
professionnels qui la trouvent
complémentaire à leur travail quotidien
des deux victimes
question c'est de sensibiliser l'opinion
publique et puis aussi les
professionnels pas que les gens qui
héberge mais les professionnels et
policiers les gendarmes les juge d'aix
était recteur les yvelines compte 165
places d'hébergement pour les femmes
victimes de violences il fait partie des
départements les mieux dotées de france
une douzaine de personnes soucieuses de
ces questions se sont rendus dans ce
local prêté par l'union locale de la cgt
de trappes le message moins que j'ai
retenu c'est que en plus de l'engagement
vraiment nationale des revendications
nationales qui est vraiment des choses
aussi à faire au niveau local et
je trouve que c'est vraiment des actions
d'avenir pour pouvoir agir contre ce
fléau
le collectif s'est donné pour objectif
de réunir cent mille personnes à la
prochaine marche nous tout le 23
novembre